[Musik]
die hochmoselbrücke in rheinland pfalz
ein mega bauwerk mitten im beschaulichen
moseltal die hochmoselbrücke verbindet
den hunsrück links mit der eifel auf der
rechten seite wir befinden uns in der
nähe von zeltingen rachtig
so sieht die riesen brücke von unten aus
und das ist der blick von oben
ein 1,7 kilometer langer stahl überbau
für die fahrbahn
der auf zehn pfeilern ruht eine maximale
höhe von rund 160 metern unter der
fahrbahn hätte sogar der kölner dom
platz
die hochmoselbrücke ein koloss aus beton
und stahl
zuständig für den stahlbau ist schweiß
fachingenieur michael arzt
35.000 tonnen stahl hat er hier mit
seinem team verbaut
noch befindet sich die fahrbahn im
rohbau
arz fährt über puren stahl und das lange
vor der verkehrsfreigabe
eines der privilegien auf der baustelle
seit 2011 wurde hier gearbeitet
auch europas größter brückenbaustelle
ursprünglich war das bauende mal für das
jahr 2016 angesetzt jetzt wird die
brücke im november 2009 10 11
[Musik]
der stahl überbau wurde vor ort aus
riesigen einzelteilen zusammen
geschweißt und dann über jahre
zentimeter für zentimeter über die zehn
brückenpfeiler und über die mosel
geschoben von links nach rechts vom
hunsrück aus in richtung eifel
[Musik]
die hochmoselbrücke ist teil eines 25
kilometer langen bundesstraßen ausbaus
dem sogenannten hochmoselübergang eine
direktverbindung zwischen den benelux
staaten und dem rhein main gebiet
was hier auf getragen wird ist
gussasphalt der untergrund für den
späteren fahrbahnbelag
210 grad heiß ist die schwarze masse
viel heißer dürfte sie nicht sein
andernfalls könnte die stahlkonstruktion
darunter schaden nehmen
viele menschen entlang der mosel sehen
in der brücke eine chance für die
gesamte region
besonders der strukturschwache hunsrück
und die eifel profitierten von der neu
geschaffenen infrastruktur
pendler kämen schneller an ihr ziel und
touristen schneller an die mosel
[Musik]
viele winzer sehen innbrücke und
bundesstraße ein riesiges problem
hier werden spitzenweine angebaut
moselwein wird von kennern auf der
ganzen welt geschätzt
der eingriff in die landschaft die
versiegelung von flächen könnte sich auf
den wasserhaushalt der weinberge
auswirken und somit auf die qualität
ihrer weine fürchten die winzer anfangs
wurde noch gegen die bauarbeiten
protestiert jetzt ist die
hochmoselbrücke fast fertig der protest
ist weitgehend verstummt windschutzwände
und leitplanken werden montiert
die letzten arbeiten vor der
verkehrsfreigabe und die beste aussicht
ins moseltal
[Musik]
so sieht die hochmoselbrücke von innen
aus der komplette stahl überbau ist
begehbar für wartungszwecke über uns
verläuft die fahrbahn vor uns eine
geöffnete gittertür im boden
so gelangt man auf die zehen
brückenpfeiler der kleinste ist 20 meter
der größte rund 150 meter hoch alle
brückenpfeiler sind innen hohl und
beinhalten entweder eine treppe oder
eine art fahrstuhl ebenfalls für spätere
wartungsarbeiten
[Musik]
die hochmoselbrücke ein bauprojekt der
superlative dass die mittelmosel region
grundlegend verändern wird
[Musik]